需要靠着父母给你钱花吗？
需要靠着父母给你房子，
你才能住房子吗？
需要靠着父母帮你给孩子做饭，
孩子才能活着吗？
你现在是一个27岁的一个女性，
你要真切的知道这个世界上什么东西是你最宝贵的东西，
如果是99年的工作的就是居家工作，
工作低点自由，
长项中等偏上一点，
目前存款是15，
其实工资呢，
就是1W，
旺记的时候可能就是3W，
这个工作呢，
专业究竟要不要继续干下去，
因为之前接不到这个活，
就比较拼嘛，
颈椎还有腰椎，
长期熬夜工作的弊端呢，
就是接触不到人，
圈子比他小，
学历就是初中毕业，
自考的本科，
目前是有两大情感的经历，
我的这个男朋友算是在我认识的人里面最优的选择吧，
他是东北吧，
00年的，
我是九九年的，
他是二本，
我是江苏这边的，
他就是比较老实，
脾气比较执拗，
没有什么不良嗜好，
但他今天发生的事情呢，
就他跟父母打电话的时候，
生气的时候可会跟父母说，
你说的不是人话，
但是我是完全理解不了的，
我觉得就是长辈不能这样讲话，
他可能也是被家里惯的吧，
他是家里的独生子，
但是他们家去了一次，
看了他们家的家庭氛围，
他们家。
处还是很和谐的，
就没有电话里动话那么难听嘛，
给我的感觉就是父母一切是为了孩子。
还有一件事儿，
就是我跟他从东北回江苏的时候，
在高铁上，
我因为工作的关系，
就是跟别人打电话有十分钟，
然后他就跟我生气，
他就觉得我休息了，
就不要处理任何工作上的事情，
但是我的工作是完全没有办法，
就是彻底的休息了，
后来就因为这么一点的小时，
他自己走了20km的路，
自己走回去了，
我是打车回去的，
就是从这件事儿就能体现到吧，
他就有点偏执的感觉，
不好相处，
但是他有很多好的地方，
他是比较宅的那种，
有时候跟我生气的时候，
可能异地恋相距70km，
吵架还会凌晨过去找我，
就是感情还是有的，
他就是我跟他一起吃饭吧，
吃不到一块儿去，
他好像没有什么喜欢的东西，
我就比较喜欢美食，
他没有什么不良嗜好，
就是有时候好像控制不了自己的情绪，
生气的时候就整个人都在发抖，
每天呢按时上班，
没有什么太大的上进心，
月收入吧，
不到1W，
就是那种无欲无求的。
目前他也没有给我花过什么钱，
过节的时候会给我送点好礼物，
现在的情况是他们家只能拿出来6W的彩礼，
20的首付，
我们家呢，
可能给我给价是10，
他们同意在江苏。
买房，
但是不愿意在我的老家买，
这点钱完全是不够的，
相距也比较远吧，
有2000km，
就算是远嫁。
我妈妈的意思就是说，
就是催我结婚，
因为到年龄了，
她说村上的人会说我总共有两段情感经历，
之前呢是在我18岁左右的时候，
那时候还在上学，
就是谈了一个早恋嘛，
我的小孩已经是10岁了，
我的女儿目前是他奶奶带，
衣食住行是挺好的，
但是教育上是欠缺的，
我父母是不同意我带她，
但是每年就是暑假、
寒假，
国庆各个节日都会带过来，
之前我会给小孩买快递啊，
寄到他们家去，
但是因为他奶奶老师在村子上乱传加说一些话，
后来我就不给他买了，
就是暑假我带小孩的时候，
可能就会提前把他需要的东西啊，
秋冬的衣服给买好了，
直接给他带回去，
我基本上算是断联的状态，
就现在小孩长大了，
有时候偶尔吧，
她可能会骑车自己去我们家，
我妈呢就劝我，
就是不要给他花太多的钱，
让我等到小孩长大了，
就是考大学结婚了再给他花钱。
目前的情况，
我男朋友就是知道我这个小孩他们也能玩到一块去，
相处了有半个月吧，
但是我男朋友的父母他们是不知道这个情况的，
我不知。
他要不要坦白，
就是她父母，
我看你也挺心疼的，
就是普通的农民，
就是独生子吧，
可能他父母知道这个情况，
大哥都不会同意我跟他在一起，
我不知道我要不要主动说，
我不认为这个男朋友是一个良拌，
是一个良配，
他性格极端偏执，
所以说可能这种性格极端偏执的人，
他在谈恋爱的时候很热烈，
会让你感受到那种强烈的被爱，
强烈的被须要，
强烈被依恋，
你会觉得很幸福，
但是真正过日子啊，
这种性格极端偏执的人，
真正的过日子是致命伤，
尤其是将来有了小孩儿是致命伤，
他还跟我说他不想要小孩，
就是以后有两个人这样过真的不行，
跟那种性格偏执的比较偏激的人生活在一起是很危险的，
就像坐高铁，
就是吵架这种事儿，
其实类似的事情已经发生好几次了，
我建议你慎重的考虑啊，
没有必要他条件没有好到那种你可以去冒这个风险的程度。
我觉得我父母想让我跟他在一起，
可能更大的原因就是因为村里的一些流言蜚语，
但是我又不想因为这个就凑合在一起，
你可以离得远一点嘛，
不用在家里待着嘛，
出去打工嘛，
挣钱去嘛，
你本来就是自由职业嘛，
为什么非得在村里待着呢？
既然说这个村儿待着，
流言蜚语挺重的，
不可以换个村。
啊，
我可以换个证嘛，
开销又不高，
反正我又自由职业，
而且我这个工作呢，
刚开始的时候我是接不到活，
就是挺辛苦的，
就搞得我现在就是年龄不大，
但是颈椎病还有腰椎病，
还有长期熬夜，
这三点都比较严重，
我就有点纠结，
那就换个工作嘛，
趁年轻已经26岁对不对，
26岁学什么都来得及啊，
行，
那我的小孩呢，
目前就是听说他爸爸可能就是进去了，
但是我不确定，
只是八九不离十，
我要就是把他带到我这边呢，
还是说继续让他奶奶带着呢？
你自己对孩子有感情吗？
喜欢跟孩子待在一块儿吗？
我也喜欢，
就是孩子喜欢跟你待在一块儿吗？
喜欢，
那为什么不接过来呢？
如果他爸都已经进去了，
现在孩子都已经十岁了，
人家生活都能自理了，
人家自己都能点个外卖，
自己要是那个什么那点动手能力强一点，
人家自己在家都能煮个泡面吃了，
因为我的大部分时间就是一直在工作，
可能就是从早上8.1直到半夜，
还有就是我的父母不同意也是一方面，
你需要靠着父母给你钱花吗？
需要靠着父母给你房子，
你才能住房子吗？
需要靠着父母帮你给孩子做饭，
孩子才能活着吗？
你现在是一个27岁的一个女性，
你要争气的。
到这个世界上，
什么东西是你最宝贵的东西？
我目前就是住在我父母的现成的房子里，
经济上就是花我自己的钱，
那我问你，
如果你带着孩子住在你父母的房子，
你父母会让你们卷铺盖卷吧滚蛋吗？
不会，
姑娘，
我没有别的意思啊，
我只是想着一个10岁的小姑娘，
如果说爸爸也不在，
爸爸坐牢了，
奶奶爷爷奶奶在的话，
如果没有一个人真正的去堡护她的，
你知道现在这个小姑娘长大的过程中会经历一些什么吗？
各种男性的亲戚，
各种男性的老师，
各种男性的邻居，
各种男性的老光棍儿，
各种男性的那个像这种没有人贴身堡护的女孩子，
在他们眼里的话，
就跟一块肉一样的，
随时都可能面临不可逆的风险，
包括在学校，
如果没有人真正爱她，
没有人真正保护她，
她容易被别人仅供你参考啊，
就不要让你的女儿走你的老路，
不要让你的女儿在十几岁的时候不懂事的时候也经历一些不可逆的这些风险，
仅供你参考啊，
好，
谢谢，
再见啊，
拜拜，
我不是有个侄女儿嘛，
我侄女儿今年12岁，
我跟我嫂子都说，
我要相信任何人，
农村如果带孩子尽量就别去我们村儿了啊，
我没有别的意思，
就是女孩子作为妈妈就应该像老鹰一样，
就应该像一个。
母鸡一样，
就应该像一头母狼一样盯着自己的孩子。
记得点赞关注哦。